if we do this we'd be going in
short-handed yeah you mean cuz he killed
all that friend we owe this to everyone
who's not in this room to try what are
some iconic moments from pass MCU movies
that are most personal to you guys and
why you and Dante together I was just I
was just thinking I've always loved
those scenes because you guys are at
least to our leaders that are like you
know these two powerful people who have
different being views very well said
it's almost like it was like it's almost
like you had already said that the last
you know banner they did this I think
the Hulk is this generation's Hamlet I'm
always you know that's my secret granted
I mean it gets to be I'm involved but
but it's our it's our moment but it's
your line it's such a nice delivery I'm
always angry it's just like the real
microcosm of what that makes the
character complex right this is
beautiful
you guys are appreciating each other
should we just get out of here wait like
we haven't had that much stuff to know
really we do a little bit but caring
years ago now yeah what's my I don't
know and I guess fighting with Zoe
Saldana is really fun
just cuz she's so good at it and I look
like spaghetti and she's like but she
made me a little better I think
we can finish this you trust me I do
what was it like for you jumping into
the Avenger so late in the game
extremely intimidating not okay just
deeply not okay not fair to do
especially on a film where you have no
script so you show up at work and have
no idea what it is that you're doing
they only give you your piece of the day
so if you're in a scene where it's lots
of other people talking you just it's
all redacted except for like your one
line did you deliver brilliantly thank
you but you don't know the context of
anything else so once you get over that
and realize that it's just fun and play
for the most part sorry for the moments
when it's not what is very serious it
was great because I'm coming into
something that has been and so much
foundation so many roots so I was just
joining a family right what was it like
for all of you guys watching the big
snap on screen or the results of the
snap on screen like was there a death or
a dusting that was like really hard for
you for the last film yeah I think that
whole sequence was pretty pretty damn
emotional yeah pretty well orchestrated
and very much nolan and that's one of
those things that we couldn't have had
that experience until we saw the whole
thing because even though we're in it
we're not knowing what's happening i
remember walking literally walking by
you and we had a beat and i was like oh
i wonder how that's gonna play if that's
gonna be the in there and it was and it
was it's yeah it's kind of a really
impactful scene that we got the full
force of seeing it in the film the first
time watching a movie was um the one
that really got me was the the
spider-man yeah yeah there was a seven
year old kid in a spider-man costume who
came in his spider-man costume to see
the movie it got him - yeah
whatever it takes
whatever it takes
heretics
whatever it takes what are you most
excited about for your upcoming Black
Widow film what what movie where who are
you in this I mean I don't know what I
know it's all news it's all news to me
it's so exciting guys I saw these we
don't know I honestly until I'm like you
know eating turkey slices at craft
service I don't actually think
anything's really happening if it
hypothetically if anything lunch meat on
set to know that it's really going on I
love that sliced turkeys like your go-to
kök' so as the Avengers as your
characters how would you guys advise
people to prep for this movie do you
feel like you have to watch all the
other movies before I would definitely
eat something before you go into the
theater cuz it's a long long bring
snacks hide some snacks
yeah yeah I mean not that we're
advocating hides no that's true don't
mind snacks or box by the 40 build a
popcorn I know they keep raising those
prices then pretty soon the girls start
charging for butter um do you guys
really have to watch all the movies
before this one is that how people
should prep for this that sounds a lot
that sounds like a lot but I mean I
think you will miss out like what you
want to at least have watched infinity
and understand like it's you know it's
of course it's all these threads coming
together right I think definitely you
should have seen infinity war so that
like you I mean that's clear but I feel
like when I saw infinity war one thing
that I was amazed at it's I thought wow
you know like you could definitely kind
of come into this movie and it really
you would know what was going I was
amazed at how the Russos like tied that
all in because there it's very plot
driven and yet I mean some of my like
family or whatever didn't haven't seen
every single movie all leading up and
they stole and like found it totally
like cohesive so I'd say infinity war
and then you're good
what we can do it is our best and
sometimes the best we can do
as your characters if you had to answer
as your characters how should people
properly strategize to watch a three
hour movie P before you go in I drink a
lot of water that's actually not a bad
idea
and then don't pee before you go in yeah
it makes it real tense it does it really
heightens the movie going to happen and
is it gonna happen soon hey oh my god
I'm gonna be myself right you know I'd
spit all over my face I said actually I
actually instead of yeah it's a peed out
of my mouth yeah
the only thing about the time I don't
think you're gonna I don't know any
movie I saw that was long it felt long I
was at the time the great thing about
this is that you know there's a lot of
them what is it the twenty second film
in the in Canon it's right and so you
know there's a lot to address and meet a
lot of people in the audience by the way
mingling with each other probably you
know making babies yeah a lot of big
you're gonna find all this out of love
but a lot of babies are gonna be born
exactly
no catch is nine money after can
deceived yeah conceived well conceived
an end boy I guess born ten months
although I won't do it during the movie
the right kids wait to left words talk
about the movie during your consolation
oh man I'm all for people just
expressing their love it almost went
into a song that would not be
appropriate really quick cuz I don't
much time left if you guys could switch
with anyone in the MCU who would it be
gracefully switching with Paul Rudd
jeremy renner I can't wait to be little
in the past MCU movies are there any
iconic moments that are very personal to
you yeah I mean a lot of a personal and
like ones that we've directed or ones
that we've watched just personal to you
they're like meaningful to you I mean I
am the original Iron Man always felt in
a really personal no way because we grew
up loving comic books and I felt like it
was the first time they're able to see
one of the more CG motivated characters
on screen in a way that felt incredibly
photo-real and I thought oh now we're
we've hit that point where these movies
can be made this way
you